onde fica outro lado eu acho que essa é
a pergunta que os filósofos os
navegadores se fizeram e acho que essa
pergunta está dentro de cada ser humano
um debate impulso no coração onde fica
outro lado nessa indagação que constam
boris estudando tambores um instrumento
que está na minha vida desde muito
pequeno
creio que meu pai e minha mãe são os
espelhos minha vida um dia pensar onde
fica outro lado esses caras eram do rio
de janeiro
além da superliga se casaram
brasília ae estou indo para brasília
neste país jogar melhor não há há há
enfim foram para brasília
na época da construção de brasília o
técnico em eletrônica não tiveram seus
filhos e os cariocas se encontravam
gaúchos gente todo o brasil terra da
oportunidade nova capital do país
um cenário colando então rio se deslocou
para lá era capital
e o restante do brasil quem tinha um
sonho onde fica outro lado vamos botar a
cara de 5 tambores foi ter acesso aos
pacotes dos cariocas ao forró dos
nordestinos
o tambor dos gaúchos também outras
empresas sempre presente na nossa vida
isso me levou também a a pesquisar
depois dos tambores e tá beleza moda
aqui comigo estava na minha mão e tal e
onde é que ficou do lado de onde veio
tanto no lado dos carros estudar
pesquisar ler tocar viajar e buscar
graças a deus meu pai e minha mãe me der
uma situação de poder ter acesso a uma
educação boa e eu sempre fui um jogador
então acredito que
uma boa educação é onde você vai criar
um cidadão de verdade
para quê questiona um cara que se
incomoda com o que a gente vê de errado
ele quer transformar aquilo em brasília
foi convidada a se retirar da escola
quando era adolescente
dá pra ver que pela minha pintamos um
cara muito fácil de lidar imagina
adolescente convidado mentirá a cena é
que aqui em curitiba da mesma
congregação e teve depois como um
funcionário dentro professor de inglês e
foi muito legal vivência dentro e
mostrar pra eles porque durante o
conselho de classe no fim do ano eu era
aquele cara que pesava os alunos janeiro
chegou a londres para passar vai
faltou um pouquinho de nota pode vai
passar deixei na mão mas aqui é bonzinho
a empresa se davam bem comuns em
separado bonzinho aquele que faz zona se
ele reprova ele porque eu sabia que ele
podia mudar eu via que acontecer eu
sabia que ele tinha um cara sensível o
coração monstro que não sabia que não
tinha como chegar a professora fernanda
fala fica quietinha no comércio paralelo
chegou o tão galera seguinte eu penso
assim
os tambores na minha vida eles vieram
trazer disciplina
espero trazer indagação nos fizeram
questionar onde fica outro lado eu posso
chegar com isso chegará à áfrica disse
que tal que chegar não queria amanhã me
não é a áfrica
a origem da civilização onde se deu a
transição do quádruplo de pub pedir para
trocar logicamente confirmada professor
cavalo esportes da universidade de
temple apostar que várias fontes para
você pesquisar fatos e não tentando não
acedeu a vida social se deu a vida
cultural que se deu a vida espiritual e
hoje a galera nega tudo isso ele fala
nelas e uma câmera
é lá que eu tô aqui o xandão também para
quem está assistindo depois também
curtir bom com um grupo de amigos uma
festa que a gente fazia distribuiu
tambores e sentir essa vai vir sentir
aqui a gente podia decidir levar isso
para dentro do educandário nossa vila
uma creche na comunidade vão
compartilhar essa vai ver que a gente
produz com esses caras vão fazer com que
eles se engajem também o que isso vai
gerar a gente chega pra galera da
faculdade a eles é mesmo um mouse mesmo
mobilizar a galera e vamos levar porque
esses caras tem que lá essa
transformação de até o brasil e até
creche que causou em mim essa reflexão
vai gerar no também digo que esse
projeto o cirandeiro ele é um projeto
que ele gera indagação gera reflexão e
um projeto baseado na experiência e
desapego e namur experiência ação gerar
uma reflexão você vai melhorar a
situação
o desapego é que vai ter que quebrar os
paradigmas e teclado da comunidade tem
medo de ser assaltado e ferrovias têm
que chegar lá e ver que a galera prole
todo mundo te abraçar
onde come um come desta tudo certo está
seguro você pode ser roubado aqui fora
lá dentro não tá então e humor porque o
amor próprio neto tem que chamar se você
não é ninguém se pode amar o outro como
realmente um ser humano então passar
pelos lugares falar com o porteiro falar
com netto ninguém menos do que ninguém
eu não se podem ter visto que a
divulgação do material a minha fala lhe
dá um jeito de carioca sido muito meu
currículo que soma no currículo é que
eles querem que nunca corri pra fazer
nada
eu dei aulas de inglês e fui salva vida
em balneário camboriu eu fui comissário
de bordo ficou três anos na vasp não
quero fazer propaganda fala que não é
pra falar nada de empresas já morreu às
empresas não fazem propaganda
sabe por que estão me vendo uma grana e
o seguinte galera sabe sim é o que a
vida me mostrou foi que desde já tem uns
15 anos o professor também sala de aula
sem o dono de inglês sir donald batuque
uma coisa que eu faço de coração tá o
nosso projeto batuque com as crianças é
um projeto interdisciplinar trabalhando
batuque com eles a gente trabalha a
questão de lateralidade esquerdo e
direito
a gente trabalha e se eu falei pra vocês
de história da humanidade história do
mundo
a gente trabalha a questão de geografia
a gente trabalha matemática contagem
rítmica
a gente trabalha a autoestima a gente
lida com manifestações populares galera
da comunidade trabalha a questão de
preconceito de raça estava nessa
aceitação esse trabalho é realmente
quebrar muros é o coletivo dame disque
quebrando o muro do povo constrói
grandes nomes em estrofes de heróis e é
nisso que a gente acredita
então eu convido vocês a quebrar em seus
muros que eu sei que todo mundo tem um
pouco do que brancos mas até hoje sobre
alguns largos lajota quem tem que dar de
martelo quebra em seus muros sabe tudo
aquilo que ensinaram para vocês na
escola vão além
eu sei que tem muitos educadores hoje
ficará como falar como educadora que eu
falar mas eu estou falando para vocês
quem está em sala de aula sem qualquer
verdade sei quem está junto há o projeto
de batuque ele é um projeto que hoje por
exemplo assim eu tenho 10 anos de
estrada com esse projeto
comecei com criança de 10 que está com
20 eu tenho um soldado em proteger a
pátria nas olimpíadas agora salve o
exército também ladrão pedido que foi o
crime mas eu chego na comunidade baixa
ele faleceu beleza que o batuque como
está e também para voltar porque ao a
galera todo mundo quer fazer parte nós
todos queremos fazer parte de um grupo
seleto
nós queremos nos sentir importante vocês
todos passaram no vestibular está aqui
hoje 1.500 inscritos 10 palmas pra vocês
ontem os fiéis sérgio 11 mas a exigência
paulo a vocês a minha mãe conseguiu
vingar as coisas estão aí então assim ó
nota falando sério é muito que se
divirtam vivendo a iom line ou então
assim galera
o projeto já que a gente faz
simplesmente foi convidar eu e meus
amigos gostava de tocar tambor a gestão
do nosso quero tocar tambor e
compartilhar aquilo que os outros
eu não sou da timbalada no soldo toca
num toque ou três caras um toque jamais
tocaria i7
mas a gente tem a gente toca a gente
consegue tocar o coração de muitas
pessoas que é pulso aqui dentro debate
ele sentir e convido vocês a quebrar
essas barreiras é que vocês estão
fazendo com seus amigos que você faz
gols tira foto tem um projeto legal
coloca a gente sozinha nos mais apto
juntos nós vamos mais longe beleza
galera vamos finalizar com um batonzinho
daqueles alto astral foi o seguinte a
galera agora do vermelho do laranja vai
bater assim ó pá vai jogar comigo vai
ter coisa tudo vai correr
o verde eo azul e roxo vão batendo
contra
vai encaixando encaixam ai ai ai
to
falhou falhou e legal que ouviu haitiano
é bom jamaicanos eles não viu a equipa
começar de novo esse tipo não
consentindo tá então o seguinte é como é
bom te gosto sim bom de novo né então o
seguinte galera
o coraçãozinho porque agora acho que
esse ambiente cheio de flores intenção
quando entrei aqui nessa casa do senhor
imagina quanta coisa que não aconteceu
aqui dentro agradeço aqui hoje
por isso o mercado e quero que se mente
esteja cheio de flores que se sintam as
pedras caindo queria comprar uma
instituição na correria hoje não
conseguiu fazer as flores bom
olha só isso o couro é assim ó tá caindo
falou é tá caindo luta lá no céu
lá na terra e tá caindo flu tá caindo e
fulô e taca enfim vai lá no céu
lá na terra preta cair flu
a taca iflow e taka em fui lá no céu na
terra
eita caiu
a cair a até a cair
ae